you guys know don lemon over at cnn and
again i said at the beginning i was
friendly
with don i don't know what happened to
him it's disappointing
to me a couple years ago you know we
used to go out for dinner and hang out
whatever and then
one day he just unfollowed me and then
sort of just you know follow me on
twitter and then just sort of
started going crazy with all this race
stuff it was not something that he was
doing before
he was actually a pretty moderate guy
from what i know i actually thought and
i think i've said to him privately
i think we're out to wings once on the
upper west side and i was like don i
think you're a conservative we kind of
laughed about it
well he's really just gone in on all of
this
nonsense we've got some quotes here from
blaze media
cnn anchor don lemon had some
unfavorable remarks about the united
states and americans in a new interview
the left-wing
cable tv host made a bizarre claim that
americans don't see black people as
human beings
and declared that the u.s needs to
realize just how racist it
racist it is i don't know if america
sees black people and especially black
gay men as fully human and as uh
deserving of the american dream lemon
said
lemon claim that we're living in two
different realities as black and white
people
but as the daily mail pointed out he
lives in a 4.3 million dollar
four-bedroom cottage in sag harbor on
new york's long island where 80
of the population is white and just 3
are black okay i don't care how much
money don lemon makes i don't really
care
where he lives or the price of his house
i'm a capitalist and i believe
that if you can make the money and do uh
well i was gonna say an honest day's
work i'm not sure he's doing an honest
day's work but
i don't think he's doing anything
illegal let's put it that way it's like
you know what
if you're making money and you live in a
fancy house on long island
good for you okay but that's not really
what this is about first off where is it
better for black people
than america i'll be silent for 10
seconds can you count to 10
please think of all the places it's
better for black people than america
yeah that's how many that's how many now
that doesn't mean it's perfect
that doesn't mean it's perfect and it
ain't perfect for anybody because
there's no such thing as perfection
we humans are flawed thus we build
flawed things but america is pretty damn
great
and that's why black people are not
fleeing america and that's why black
people
world over are still trying to come to
america and so are other such brown
people
and often white people it's very very
bizarre so that's just nonsense
uh absolute nonsense and i mean i say
the same things all the time but it's
like
just worth repeating that we fought a
war to end slavery
we just put uh june 19th
as a national holiday like there's a
whole bunch of stuff here lemon
and that they don't like black gay men
like what
are where are black gay men being hunted
down where are black people being hunted
you know where actually
chicago chicago you may have seen some
of the videos this past weekend
of just people being shot on the streets
i mean there's some really horrific
videos
of black on black crime in chicago i
know we can't talk about that and even
me saying that
watching black people get shot down i
mean mowed down by gun violence in
chicago
that makes me a racist i know that um
but here i am i said anyway can we find
out how many people were shot in chicago
this past weekend it's usually around 40
it's about 40 people usually a weekend
and then usually about
five or ten of them die but that's black
on black crime so we can't talk about
that although
mayor lori lightfoot who's black and
said that she'll only be interviewed
by black or brown people uh she just put
10 million dollars of her
city's money in chicago to fight racism
which that's just a way of like paying
off people that's literally just a way
of
10 million to fight racism you got
people being shot on the street
here's 10 million dollars to a bunch of
organizations that just don't do
anything
but they fight racism oh 52 people were
shot
in chicago this past weekend five
fatally according
to the chicago sun times guessing you
didn't see any of that on mainstream
media because
again it's that narrative over truth and
reality that they don't really like
but let's just be clear america does not
have a problem with black people the
only people that
have the obsessive people who are who
are constantly
harping on race are the democrats are
the progressives are the lefties
nobody cares nobody cares about race
anymore
you guys care about race and the better
things get about race
the more you have to focus on your
imaginary problem
and what they are going to do i mean
i've been saying this for quite some
time already but what they are going to
do they are going to breed a generation
of racists because if you keep telling
white people that they're all evil and
then you make it harder for them to get
jobs and then harder to get loans and
all of those things eventually you will
create racist people because nobody is
guilty
over the color of their skin nobody is
born
guilty these people are in an absolute
cult and the idea that nobody
nobody likes black gay men you're a
black gay [ __ ] i mean that's what you
are
right it has nothing to do with you
being black and it has nothing to do
with you being gay
your ideas are idiotic you're on a prime
time show making millions of dollars a
year
to live in a multi-million dollar house
in long island while telling us all how
horrible we are
god these people are fools